[Applause]
my god
i'm taller than everybody that comes on
this show then you've just thrown the
whole curve off how tall are you exactly
five eleven and a half yeah i really am
really depressed
it's a big half last is a big help
uh congratulations on the book coming
out who's running the asylum you have
some uh
make some pretty interesting statements
here you you talk about in your prime
how you think you would have maybe uh
stacked up against shaquille o'neal
or you know what do you think might
would have happened you versus shaquille
o'neal today because
people sometimes lump the two of you
together yeah because we're both
terrible foul shooters but uh other than
that uh
shaquille and i is like comparing me
with clark gable mm-hmm
in this case i'm claude gable and he's
uh he's me
no he thought you were going to be
self-effacing for a second and then no
no no nothing like that no he uh plays
an entirely different type of basketball
game
he uses his physicality and he's a big
strong young man
and that works well in today's game if
he was facing me
and other guys of my time not so not so
good
i mean i'm a guy bench pressing around
600 pounds when i was at my
six hundred pounds yeah right so i'm at
five ten that's pretty good i'm gonna
work on it a little while i'll be in
your league my friend right right that's
why you better be rather nice to me
here you know and i'm a little surprised
because i know you wanna talk about a
subject that uh
is dealing with my heart well we got to
talk about this you made a statement and
and and this statement is going to
follow you around for a while that you
for a while
that you slept with 20 000 women you
made that statement
now and i you know and i got to say
that's uh that's the kind of thing that
you say and then people bring it up
later
on you just push people like you right
exactly
it's not just me have you seen there's a
clock in times square take a look at
this thing
it's pretty incredible yeah i didn't
think that uh
oh right yeah okay yeah
yeah now i'm curious yeah i'm curious
i want to know about my family's share
that's the part i'm curious about
well first of all it was encounters but
you know i thought maybe one of the
reasons you invited me on the show
was to give me an award from the board
of education
because whenever people see me now they
go 20
000 and let's see he must have started
he was like 15
he's now maybe 55. so let's see 20
365 into 20 000.
and uh you know and then you're getting
people thinking
not only that i'm teaching them which is
really the whole the whole story here
you understand i don't think that's
going to be a word problem for kids
if will chamberlain is with 10 women on
a train headed east that's right
that's right and when he gets to
missouri
all right but uh but but on the serious
side of that though you know just so
women don't think me of being really
whatever
uh the number was uh to make a statement
about something and it was not ever
to sort of like uh be little
the ladies that i've known and make them
just another number
in fact in in my in my book they were a
number really a great looking number as
they were i understand but
uh what i was trying to say in my 20 000
right
that's all i'm thinking as you're
talking i'm not hearing anything there's
nothing wrong with short
short romance you keep fading out of the
number twenty thousand thousand dollars
nothing wrong with short romance believe
me short romance as long as it's a happy
thing yeah going on right believe me
but the idea was to say that you know
sexually rules the world
and that you know for men who think that
having 1 000 different women is really
cool
i have found out but you have to first
find out mm-hmm they're having one woman
a thousand different times of what's
really happening
oh but how'd you yeah right here let's
let's just happen yeah
yeah now go ahead and see you
had sex a thousand 20 a thousand times
with each of the 20
000. that's what i'm thinking now
i'm really impressed it takes stamina it
takes stamina it takes damage all right
well let's talk about another number all
right
let's talk about the number 100 points
in one game which i believe was versus
the knicks 1962.
that's right is that right a long long
time ago right yeah right right
was there a point 100 points in one game
was there a point where where just the
other team like left and made sandwiches
on the bench i mean
well i really wish it was actually they
were really very embarrassed about the
whole thing
mm-hmm and so they were mad at me you
know and i was just out there trying to
have fun did you start to like
at 85 points did you start to feel bad a
little bit yeah absolutely and the
people
i'll just try and miss this one a
hundred times i did that i know i did
did that then my mother scolded me when
i got home you should be sharing
yourself
you know it was it was not an easy night
now yeah because i have a lot of friends
on the next let's talk about uh well
michael jordan
i'm curious uh michael jordan say we had
a time machine here
and we could send michael jordan back to
the civil war no that's stupid
that's just my own fantasy you know uh
what if we could send michael jordan uh
back to playing uh basketball with you
in your prime
all right how do you think he would do
in those days well first of all i'm glad
you said with me
you know and not and not again me uh
michael jordan is one of those rare
specimens that
could have played at any particular time
and is a gifted uh
gifted athlete who is using those gifts
uh in basketball
incredibly so he has been the liaison
between
something that's not so good and making
it great for all the rest i think that
almost every man in the nba should give
him 10 of their checks
now what would his playing style how
would that have translated back well his
playing style is he's six foot seven
and he's uh like 197 pounds uh
coming into what we call our domain the
pivot for us big guys
we've not been very wise of michael you
know if he was playing during our time
uh so we would say michael you know as
long as you do all those fancy things
outside of where we are that's fine so
it wouldn't it wouldn't have been good
for michael
really no you think he'd have been
crushed is what you're saying
i don't think i know you've been crushed
right yeah really he just wouldn't have
worked back then
no he would have came in there once or
twice 360 degree whip around dunk
people thought of that at the time well
you know what i'm glad you said that
because you see the mentality of the fan
today
is wonderful and they've learned to
accept showbiz right
and michael is the epitome of showbiz
along with that great town
during my time if you did a 360 first of
all uh the
opposition would take it as an insult
that you would try to do something like
that against them
uh the coach on your own team if you
weren't at least 90 000 points ahead
would bench you and the fans will look
at you like wow he's the biggest hot dog
in the world
you're saying michael jordan back then
would have been on the bench the whole
time absolutely uh you know being
considered hot
think about that and that's that's the
truth really but now in chicago if he
doesn't give you one of those three
sixes you're talking about
right even though their team is 90
points ahead right they're looking for
something spectacular
fans will turn right or you're right
back then it was more about teamwork
working together absolutely absolutely
what's happened to basketball were you a
basketball player
who me well i had i used to like to play
basketball but uh and i always had the
height and everything i lacked what's
called
coordination and it's true
and i found out later that you need that
i didn't wear i was one of those guys
who's like to me to me
you know and then and i'd get it and i'd
i fell a lot yeah i wept openly
sometimes
during the game it was just a messy
thing that could be a problem yeah yeah
you know yeah but still out of giving
you a run for your money
yeah okay all right now uh we'll talk
about a record so this this this blew me
away but uh
you uh you're a competitive guy okay and
you
i didn't know this this translates into
your personal life you like to drive
cross-country and some people do i've
driven cross-country a few times i enjoy
it
but you like to do it really fast is
that the case absolutely
absolutely how fast are we talking about
here well we're talking about trying to
average
up in the 130s and go as high as 170 580
miles an hour
you know and that's a non-stop drive
from like this in a volkswagen bug
that's the impression well i did i did a
commercial for volkswagen
with a little different engine but you
know but what are you talking about how
can you go that fast and not be
constantly pulled over what happens
well you have to be clever you have to
use your eyes clever
you're going 180 miles an hour
everything's a blur you're just yeah
well birds are just piling up on your
windshield clever bird or clever clever
blur
you also you also you like to um i i
i i this i found kind of interesting but
you you have a
a method for sort of like killing time
but when you see that you're six miles
out of denver and you're on the road
going 150 miles an hour what do you do
to try and kill
i hold my breath and see if i can hold
my breath all the way to denver
like it was eight or nine miles away you
know and uh so i work you know i gotta
work my way up though when i start in
new york i can only hold my breath about
like a minute
and by the time i'm halfway across the
country i can get up to almost five five
and a half minutes
you know holding my breath what i would
love to see i would love to be the
see the policeman who pulls you over
right going 125 miles an hour pulls you
over walks up
looks into the windshield it's wilt
chamberlain there and he goes
and then passes out so that's just to
amuse yourself yeah it is and i sure
wouldn't advise anyone to do it because
it's one of the dumbest things that one
could possibly do
thanks for adding that they don't like
people out there holding their breath
to the point of passing out what they're
driving a car 125 miles an hour and you
definitely compare it past south just
yet you also you like to water ski at
great speeds
yeah i tried for the quarter mile water
ski speed record 126 miles an hour it
was
you know what you can't water ski 125
miles an hour well i can and now
an idea you got to have big feet man you
understand you know it helps out you
didn't use skis
no i use i use skis in fact
i don't i would just love to see the old
fisherman now sitting on the dock and
that's exactly right i think that was
will chamberlain going by
well we are incredible we used to ski on
the sacramento river
in california and there was a highway
right right by the
the river and the cars would be going 78
miles an hour and we would just
run past the cars you know and then we
would slow up and see their expressions
on their face because they couldn't
leave it either
okay well there's that and plenty more
in this book who's running the asylum
the insane world of sports today
and uh it was great to meet you finally
very nice to have you on the program can
you come back sometime i'm gonna tell
you something i enjoy your program i
really watch it so i want to say it so
you are funny
you understand you are you are funny
[Applause]
he actually watched the show all right
will chamberlain thank you very much
mary chapin carpenter
you